one of the reasons the twins have had a
great september they've gotten two
really good starts from michael pineda
came off the suspended list and
has looked every bit as sharp as he did
in the second half last year
taking on the indians for the first time
this year the lead off manly door steps
in the box
swung on drilled up the middle of base
hit into center field for frankie lindor
lindor has really swung the bat well
this weekend
here is cesar hernandez and it's bonnet
towards the mound pineda's up with it
bare hand grab and throw
he got him and the indians may challenge
it see the first see him right there at
first basically it's safe
yeah my bad i messed up so there was no
replay review the umpires got together
talked about it and said
it's a fun single they went old school
right there and decided on the field
without replay
so indians on first and second nobody
out now the red hot jose ramirez
looking for a strikeout and he got it
three pitches
one down the runners stay at first and
second this has been an ongoing thing
for the indians this year the indians
are one of major league baseball's worst
clutch hitting teams that'll bring up
carlos santana
swings and drives one to left field and
it bloops in
for a base hit scoring with a slide is
lindor
and everybody else moves up on the
throwing air by eddie rosario
and the indians have a one-nothing lead
and a chance for a big inning ray is the
battery strike three called on a slider
so reyes strikes out two down we're only
13 minutes into the game but this is a
huge bat if pineda can get naked and get
out of this with just one run allowed
to be huge got him what a job by pineda
that's got to be more satisfying than a
one two three inning he kept the twins
in the ball game
the indians go with the youngster
tristan mckenzie here in the
season finale with minnesota kepler back
in the lineup after a 10-day stint on
the
injured ledge one gun line shot to
center coming on mercado makes the
shoulder high catch
and that is out number one here's josh
donaldson swung on and missed good
breaking ball in the outside
corner mackenzie strikes out donaldson
for the second out
here's jorge polanco the switch hitting
shortstop
swung on a lazy fly to left josh naylor
puts it away in a good one two three
inning for tristan mckenzie and two on
one out well here's carlos santana
santana loves hitting in this park swing
and a ground ball
through the hole into right field of
base hit around third lindor is gonna
score
so carlos santana two for two is driven
in both
runs today and the indians lead is two
to nothing and now runners at the
corners for reyes
3-2 hit in the air deep right field
kepler's back on the track
he's out of room and makes the catch the
indians will get a run as hernandez
tags and scores it's three to nothing
the twins have to swing the momentum in
this game mckenzie's throwing the ball
very well but a lead off walk and
change things in a hurry get him out of
the stretch disrupt his rhythm here
comes marwyn gonzalez coming off a big
night a night he needed last night
swanson launches into right that's deep
nick went on the track at the wall
that ball's gone gonzalez does it again
homer's out to right and the twins
answer right back and now trailed by
only one it's a 3-2 cleveland lead
one away for nelson cruz who struck out
his first time up continuing
a rough season against indians pitching
they have handled him extremely well
as this ball is lifted into left field
hit fairly well long run left fielder up
to the wall
and gone cruz has tied it up 3-3
on his 16th home run the home run ball
just killing the tribe this weekend the
twins have
15 total hits in this series nine have
been home runs
the indians threatening here in the
fifth inning first and second two down
and it'll be left-handed caleb
thielbarger face left-hander tyler and
england
fastball burned the outside corner and
on three pitches
naked strikes out and theobar strands
two runners
a hit batter leading off the inning ryan
jeffers is the batter
there's a high drive left center field
headed to the bullpen it's back
and it is called a home run for jeffers
and he gives the twins their first lead
and he's got to touch first
base before he can advance what is it
about the bottom part of this lineup
they are tattooing the try it's
unbelievable
unfortunately for mckenzie only three
hits allowed all of them home runs
that's it for tristan mckenzie his day
is done
cal quattro is coming on and relief josh
donaldson
will be the batter driven to the gap
left center field headed toward the
bullpen again
and go on a home run donaldson with the
fourth home
run of the afternoon this is exactly
what you wanted to see from this team
at the right time and minnesota pulling
away
now leads it six to three the indians
have first and third one out
tying run at the plate it'll be
francisco lindor and he lines one the
other way but it's right at rosario
two down tagging and coming home to
score is josh naylor
and it's a six four ball game now
they're loaded for gonzalez
down the right field line with the catch
cruz is heading home
here's the throw coming through not in
time
and gonzalez gets the twins some
insurance with a fly ball
lead off double for naquin to begin the
cleveland eighth inning
cindy leone will swing it left-handed a
swing and a shock to right base hit near
the line
naquin's around third heading for home
makes it a seven to five ball game
would rocco bulldelly bring in sergio
romo to face
lindor you wish he would don't you he's
going to stick with stacia
such a big bat for the indian such a key
at bat for lindor
fly ball left center field deep in the
gap eddie chasing byron chasing byron
over byron catches it
as he collides with rosario byron makes
the play
eddie is down for now bent his wrist
back
wrist little shoulder little uh not
something you want to see hopefully he's
all right
two on two out seven to five minnesota
in the ninth and the last hope is
tyler naked what's going to fly ball
center field buxton there
he's calling he's cutching and the twins
win the game
seven to five and sweep the weekend
series here at target field